les policiers ont des armes ils sont ils
n'ont ils n'ont pas la formation
nécessaire ils ont pas assez payés ils
travaillent dans des conditions
difficiles ou même vous n'avez pas la
haine des flics il y a des bons et les
mauvais flics
il y a une série de bavures en 93 il y a
eu
il y a ma comique qui s'est fait tirer
une balle dans la tête dans un
commissariat du 18e et puis il y a un
enchaînement de choses qui fait que on
peut se poser la question comment
aujourd'hui dans ce pays on peut se
lever le matin et se prendre une balle
dans la tête le soir on met ça en miroir
évidemment rapport à Nice qui a changé
finalement entre cette époque et
aujourd'hui c'est qu'à l'époque on
n'avait pas les portables on pouvait pas
filmer et aujourd'hui on filme en fait
on doit aussi parler de de formation et
les gens qui sont censés nous protéger
vraiment on doit faire en sorte qu'il
soit en capacité de nous protéger
réellement et pas devenir cela même
qu'il combattent d'une certaine manière
mais évidemment je comprends la colère
évidemment
[Musique]